oh hello hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to our own light
now this is a chapter one of an
interesting looking game I'm not
entirely sure if it's absolutely horror
or if it's some sort of exploratory
adventure game before the incident
Wednesday August 24th 2007
got a baby crying
explode sure and then jump forward 10
years for intake Castilla's building
when I was about the most hype entrance
to a game I've seen in a while ah-oh
find a comfortable place to work at is
that my objective okay all right
hello I this looks comfy oh I can
imagine working on a couch work here oh
yeah I didn't know we were gonna be
soothed by smooth jazz okay ah is my TV
bleeding all over my face I can't move I
think you were brought back to your home
after getting dizzy and pale until you
fainted during work
[Music]
I have no idea I'm so confused right now
but I'm not opposed I guess can I get up
is this where I get up or is this where
I just wait some more okay
okay love you too bye bye smooches Phil
was that is that our daughter all right
also I'm confounded thanks those doors
sound effects really immerse me in this
experience here ah yes great okay so why
wait a minute wait wait I wait a minute
good layout of this house is exactly the
same as Mortimer I just connected that
no this house is exactly the same this
hallway is the same is this the same yes
it's the same this is a continuation or
is this sister what is squeak squawking
[Music]
maybe the keys up step Oh back door is
locked from the inside
oh that makes sense oh that does make
sense okay I like the way that is okay
[Music]
that's nice you talked about a
mysterious little girl and you left me
alone it okay this is different now
[Music]
righty-ho then right here I hope there
is aims to be stuck someone's trying to
help me on the other side by bashing it
open a little like that
I don't like this at all I don't know
what I'm what are we doing here hi okay
you keep at that one now I'll just stay
up here tower for my family together oh
you can stop that any day now
oh hi now you will die smiley face
it's you're happy about it wait oh I get
it
the thing on my phone it wasn't a phone
call it was a voice message that I was
listening to free oh hi okay oh wow this
star K and I was listening to it over to
hear the voice to hear the voice of my
family and they died and is my daughter
trying to get vengeance upon me Oh No
oh I'm here now hello hi how you doing
[Applause]
[Music]
dammit this is chapter one not a demo
I'm heartbroken you can't just bring it
to the most good juicy part good ninjas
leave me blueballed okay so I couldn't
leave here with that again it was too
short not enough happened so I've got
another demo here of a horror game now
hopefully something more happens here
because I did see that there might be
mannequins in this one and as much as I
don't like mannequins I know that you
guys know I don't like mannequins and
sometimes that's more boo-boo in my eyes
hello
okay hi
I got squid I can't see it come closer
come into my loving arms hello
hidey-hidey-ho who are you why are you
just sitting there with an app Pole oh
don't get up don't get up don't get up
you don't need to get up
hi hello are you from Second Life I'll
take it I guess okay I'll take the Apple
okay I ate it it was delicious food that
behind you
I didn't see the gun at first all great
okay
well this is off to a great start and
now I'm going through the 2001 a Space
Odyssey tunnel I mean that's a hell of
an opening I'm not complaining about
that okay yeah sure no let me squint
what's over there hi okay sure
this is creepy Oh what is this oh oh
okay a choice it's a Stanley parable
all over again hi mr. eyeball how you
doing over there I don't like the soft
squishy sounds
ah good I guess I won't go through that
one you know I was thinking about it
bashing my head up against a brick wall
for a few hours you know I thought all
right
are you something whoa oh no that's
something oh hi hello ma'am
don't get up don't get up hey where'd
you go
all right you still there I'm just gonna
trip on you don't have a flashlight okay
yeah it's a different concept of going
down hallways cuz I can't see what's at
the end of the hall art hi hello who are
you
nice ass okay don't turn around don't
get up
hi oh well need some help there
oh hi okay hello everybody in here ah
great good cool stuff ah so uh how we
all doing how you guys doing you do you
good
good you guys look good like that like
that at all hi okay
okay great why-why-why right now oh I
got my bear repelling circle wait that's
a circle that was from the movie arrival
is what I was trying to say there whoa
hey okay then all right cool
I'll go down this hallway sure yeah that
sounds like what I want to do great cool
yeah cool yeah great okay I'll go left
this time just cuz I feel like it I
don't know what's gonna mean for me but
I'll go that way
goodness gravy oh this all wouldn't have
mattered though they were both down the
same hallway
[Music]
oh hi didn't almost didn't notice you
there from the sounds coming off that
way alright cool
you're doing great with whatever it is
that you're doing could you allow me
some time alone and you go [ __ ] off and
die
that'd be great - wait excuse you excuse
you excuse you wanna go burn like i
farted himself out of oblivion ah very
okay it's dark in here
uh oh okay alrighty then where are we
now
Wow hello hi how are you doing great
that's cute hmm nice paintings
ah good still can't see right still a
little blurry down there but that's our
[Music]
are you doing you good you good bro you
good
oh this one might be my favorite
[Music]
did wealth in darkness again really
that's what it's no it's not locked
okay Oh more art it's like I'm in the
Museum of the macabre the macabre I mean
if there was ever a game oh oh hey are
you doing okay well I'm ugly no one here
get out alive I think I might be already
dead
so I think getting out alive at this
point is the least of my concerns how
can I get out alive when there's no door
behind me now okay I know you're gonna
play this game I've seen this game many
many times in my previous life yeah he
usually starts and ends with me being
jumpscared but oh now there's a door I
like that real good oh yes I'll stand in
the closet and then wait for it to
change again thank you yes I'll do that
great where am i No
ah there's the door just have to turn a
little bit let my eyes adjust to it menu
okay well ah yes
great cool awesome fantastic oh hello
[Music]
I didn't think so I didn't think so I
didn't think so I didn't think so if you
wanna mess with me you gonna get the
horns I don't know what that means but
I've heard of it as an expression before
and I think it means [ __ ] you can't even
see in this one just gonna trust just
gonna trust another double feature for
you guys
and not too shabby it wouldn't so that
was no Med and that was out of light I
like the option of doing these double
features because it showcases these
interesting concepts because this was a
demo and that was a demo and each of
them had something going for it but
wasn't quite there
this one had something going for it I
like the the blurriness of the hallway
the unseeing the walking slowly like it
was good but it wasn't like fully there
the other one liked it at the ambience
it had the idea the story was there but
it wasn't it didn't close it off so
thank you everybody so much for watching
you can check out both of these games
through the links in the description
below
this one's apparently going on
greenlight and just thanks for watching
let me know what you thought of these
down the comments below I know there's
potential in these the developers just
got to take a few more steps further
before I'm really sold on the idea but
good potentials so far so thank you
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]